kids have a right to become who they're
capable of being they come to you with
all these different aspects of who they
are
school choice meets that need precisely
hi I'm Nicolas we with reason TV and
today we're talking with Lisa Graham
Keegan she was the Arizona
Superintendent of Public Instruction
from 1995 to 2001 as a legislator in the
Arizona Legislature before that she
sponsored the most comprehensive charter
school law in existence she helped
create Arizona state standards she's
been an adviser to John McCain Oertel
Schwarzenegger Jeb Bush Newt Gingrich
and she is now the head of the Keegan
company and works with a four Arizona
school choice and educational
consultancy firms and in 2013 you read a
great memoir which will talk about
simple choices Lisa you know we talk a
lot when we talk about school choice of
it okay well this will help increase
test scores this and that what's the
moral case for school choice well
because education is how people sort of
fulfill their humanity that's not a
small thing
so moral cases that kids have a right to
become who they're capable of being and
the other moral case I would make is for
teachers themselves to be able to
innovate you see a need you see a way
you could reach a bunch of kids we
should be able to do that and that only
happens in schools that work for them
you cannot meet every child's need with
a system that is just sort of we'll get
a hundred more kids we need a hundred
more seats we're going to have
everybody's needs met by one system one
methodology it doesn't work what holds
them back in a kind of traditional or a
conventional public school district or
model so if you think about a private or
a charter school or a market-driven
school if you and I wanted to create a
school we'd create a model first I know
I'd say well what do you think how
should we do this we'd sit down we'd get
it on paper we'd say Nick's gonna do
this Lisa will do this we're gonna reach
the kids this way this is a great way to
teach there's a model before there's a
school in the traditional system there's
a school just because there's kids and
then if we get around to building a
model there's a model it's a very I
think almost a demoralizing way to
approach education which should be just
incredibly energizing and quite
specific with that comes the assumption
that we just do the best we can that's
my least favorite expression in the
industry and I hear it every day well
you know we've got those kids yeah
those capital T capital K those kids and
there you name it they didn't have
breakfast their parents don't care they
don't have money well they have huge
capacity so I don't know how does this
change that model how does it how does
it flip it or fracture it or move past
it it really just flips it on its head I
I hate the way we we fund schools right
just everything about it first of all I
don't like drawing geographic boundaries
and giving people proxy for kids saying
oh look we drew a boundary you get to
educate everybody in there why that
there's a school across the street that
literally across the block outside the
boundary would be better for my child I
don't like it so you know some school
districts will be able to spend twenty
thousand dollars per student others can
only scrape together ten thousand is
there a role for kind of equalization of
per student funding at the state or at
the federal level or is that just
missing a bigger picture so I wouldn't
do it at the federal level if I had my
way with a magic wand I would I would
ask for state-funded programs based on
the needs of kids you put the money as
close to the child as possible I started
saying years ago that we should have a
backpack
money should go in there wherever the
kids go the money goes because that's
obviously a choice that's gonna work for
that family or they'll move and the
money will move so that still the system
I've been chasing for 25 years I think
it works because when it works for the
child the money is available to the
school talked about I mean a number of
major school districts around the
country and in very different areas
certainly very different populations
have tried backpack funding or something
approaching it what have the results
been so far so far nobody's done it
full-out nixed so a lot of people are
trying and there are now entire
companies that have come up around
figuring out how to do this how to take
the old chart of accounts and move it to
kids to me that's a marketplace sign
that we're making huge progress 20 years
ago none of those companies existed so
states are trying more and more I know
we're doing it in Arizona to try to get
to transparency what are the kids in
your school worth right most states wait
kids depending on their needs specially
it gets more money as it should learning
in the language gets more money as I
show
some states wait poverty and they give
you more money for that so that money
really attaches to the child but you
don't see it at the school site right
right so that's the next game right
let's see it talk a little bit about the
scholarship programs and and the tax
incentives that go into that for people
who don't necessarily have kids in the
school system to fund school
scholarships and things like that that
are in Arizona and a couple of other
places so in 1997 we started at wishing
tax credit program one for private
schools meaning that anybody with any
income tax liability can use a portion
of that and send it to a scholarship
organization and then we created another
one for public schools so that they
could use it for extracurriculars a
smaller amount but that's been hugely
successful and over the past couple of
years we've added education savings
accounts for private schools so and that
works like a medical savings account or
a health savings account it's a debit
card and it really is money following
kids how are the educational savings
accounts funded they're direct so maybe
90% of what you would get from the state
you would you have the ability to spend
on a private school supplemental
education etc the state says to every
student or not every fun
so particular classes of students so
students in failing schools so that's a
desperate need immediately we offer them
to students with special needs so if
your student is in one of these classes
you have the ability to use the money we
would otherwise use in a traditional
public school for other options okay so
that's true backpack funding really it
really is it really is direct public
funding the tax credit never becomes
public money and that was the court
decision on that which I'd love Supreme
Court ruling yeah I think you've got to
have a sector of Education that
government doesn't touch I really do I
mean at the college level you know
schools like Harvard you know they have
a bazillion dollar endowment they don't
need money but they'll get a lot of
money and in Arizona is that mostly like
well-off prep schools that are getting
funded on that or is it religious
schools that are serving lower-income
households or what it's everybody so my
favorite scholarship organizations are
targeted to hiney
yes we did not set an amount of money
that had to go to low-income kids in
that program and I was part of that
decision and thought you know the
markets gonna run on this these
scholarship organizations are gonna tend
towards people without money let me just
say that that is not true Nick and as it
turns out people will seek ways to get
these things to advantage themselves
how'd I did do it all over again I I
don't know what I would have done
because if you keep it just for
low-income families the political
stability is less you know the best
thing about marketplaces is it teaches
what people really want the fact is
people really want these choices and
particularly in Arizona where we let it
grow through all through the
socio-economic sectors a lot of charter
schools are keyed on very low income
families which is the biggest need and
that's where my heart is the political
world actually runs in wealth and you
can like that or dislike it but the
political reality around that is that's
what's going to turn the corner for
Arizona you know the early kind of
charter school or school choice movement
was geared towards low income often
minority students who are not being
served by traditional public schools but
for middle class upper middle class
parents what are where the charters
oriented around whatever just high
academic achievement really really
international calculus all of that kind
of sweet yeah and what's really
interesting make is that in suburban
places everybody thinks our schools are
great you know they look great I love
the geraniums out front you know my kids
are really fabulous yours are fabulous
we're all awesome and then you get this
school right next door to you where the
kids are just kicking it and wait what
you're doing you're taking what and so
that over 20 years has had a massive
effect in Arizona in suburban areas and
so these schools they have wait lists
all over the place they're they're
coming up new every year they're the
fastest-growing sector of Arizona's
education and so it's just a notch above
what are the big impediments of school
choice I mean you know the first charter
school law was passed in okay I mean
since then so we went from zero to tens
of thousands of children attending
charter schools what are the big
impediments to this radical idea just
people regardless of their income should
be able to have a choice in where their
kids go to school and and some say in
what's going on in that school well it
depends who you are but most of the
pushback comes from those who are locked
into the traditional system so local
control meaning local school districts
were meant to serve
everybody's need wherever you live
that's your school that's the one you
have to pay and here's another issue one
of the things we use in these boundaries
are taxes for construction and I just
have a huge problem with the amount of
money that gets wasted in construction
and the property taxes on that in
Arizona in particular we build these
massive facilities 20 acres standard for
elementary school 40 acres for high
school everybody's got a stadium there
is no way to pay people to teach what
you should be able to pay them if you're
going to keep building those behemoth
things well we do that on local property
is that partly though you know it's
often seen as a bug in the school
funding system but maybe it's the
purpose that if you are raising taxes to
build these big buildings you create
property taxes that effectively price
out many people from that school
district so you know it's it's a way of
maintaining a public school district
that's only for people who can make X
amount of money and it kind of keeps
people out well that's the effect I
don't know if that's the intention I
don't know that people do that
intentionally I mean it's a noble thing
to want to be on the local school board
but unfortunately we gave them the job
of being local monopolist that's a bad
idea and we gave them the wrong job and
so that the biggest pushback really
comes from that tradition and when you
say we're gonna also have public schools
that are free to move free to hire free
to use their money the way they want to
you hear the expression while they're
taking our money well no actually we
meant for the money to be for kids the
point in which we started making money
about the system and not kids is when we
allow that culture to develop which is
local control means I get to school
everybody and get paid for everybody
you're not going to be able to go from
school board to school board to say look
you got it all wrong do this what's the
best way to just kind of get around that
or leave that in the past because it's
not a conversation worth engaging in
anymore that was a whole conversation
between before we passed Arizona's law
in 1994 for charter schools up until
that point you asked your local school
board could we start
an independent school no is yes this is
basically saying we're educating
everybody in Arizona we said how about
this how about we just create a state
board for charter schools so if there
are teachers who want to start schools
they can do it and then we went around
and the funding for that would be a
portion I remember the first state to
say all the operational funding that
would go to any student is going to come
out of the state general fund and it's
kind of follow kids it's become a
problem in Arizona because the only
thing growing now in Arizona is the
charter system and that is a huge weight
you know sort of on jet on the general
fund but that's easy to fix
and it was worth doing it to go around
think one of the questions that are
asked about charter schools is that well
they're not really accountable what are
the arguments for standards either
statewide or local standards or national
standards so charter schools are
accountable on every front much more
accountable in that they have a board
that puts them into business so you have
to apply we have to take our model to
the board and say we're gonna do good
things and somebody's I said why that
proof prove that does before you even
start then you have to take the same
assessments everybody else takes and
just a sidebar on standards they have a
huge fan a very clear very minimal very
obvious standards we know what it means
to read and write at certain ages we
know what it means to do mathematics I
think we we limited to that but we make
sure I just don't get all into the
kerfuffle about who made them up and who
they're really if they're rational and
they're reasonable and they're about
what kids need to know and not how you
get there yeah that's a great thing and
you know what hasn't said how does that
play out in Arizona and you know how do
you keep it minimal as opposed to okay
well it's good to read and write but
then you also have to have these courses
in place whether or not we test them but
you know to teach citizenship or this
type of hygiene or whatever I think well
I had a superintendent say to me the
other day the biggest problem we've got
in Arizona right now is we're on hiatus
like everybody else we grade our schools
a throughout we use the state tests
right now everybody sort of is an A & B
school so the new test supposed to be
honest and we're gonna get a little more
serious about that but the fact of the
matter is well we don't have a grave the
superintendent was saying look I've had
people in my my office today I'm
supposed to wear a purple shirt because
of domestic violence my kids are
supposed to be in a bullying program
it's football season and the coach wants
this said without that assessment on the
table every year with some consequence a
through F you're gonna get graded he
said these other things just encroach
and I guarantee you everybody loses
focus when parents are or and even kids
are choosing to go to a particular
school will they generate the
information they need in order to make
an informed choice out of consumer
demand because I know if I have my kids
and I can pick from 10 different schools
if the schools are like just trust us
we're you know we're really awesome or
like yeah you know I'm you know that's
going to be hard for me to take but that
will that take the place or will that
supplement kind of these rudimentary
state assessments so we're gonna have
state assessments for a while Nick in an
ideal world the one I'd like to live in
people would be so knowledgeable about
indicators that you wouldn't need one
state test right but even if people were
using different indicators it would be
based on roughly the same standards I
mean it turns out the Pythagorean
theorem matters and it's exactly the
same in Florida as it is in Arizona and
at some point you have to teach and you
have to know how to do it if you can
understand math what worries me is that
we won't focus enough on the choices
available and that will start to get
into the process and that does happen
you know you have to teach this textbook
is you say you have to have a hygiene
class whatever they need to be minimal
strong honest and that's always gonna be
a fight talk a little bit about it's
already an issue among Republican
presidential candidates Common Core
which started out as a bunch of
conservative mostly Republican governors
pushing this a decade or so ago people
like Jeb Bush who's done very well in
terms of by most standards or
evaluations of education reform John
Kasich in Ohio is that the wrong way to
kind of set standards or you know where
is it a good idea and it's just being
given a bad rap in the press it's a good
idea to have been voluntary make it
really was a voluntary effort and it was
an effort to be honest like if I can
compare Arizona to Ohio there's a
greater likelihood this was the theory
that we're all gonna be more honest
about how our kids are really doing what
creeps into it is everybody's politics
and
I I have set aside the whole common cord
to pay for myself and just gone around
it kind of like school choice hey you
guys can all fight about that if you
want to it really has more to do with
the politics of discrete ways of
teaching which really are not about the
standards themselves and I understand
people's nervous about that I don't want
you telling me I have to teach math a
particular way but I should be okay with
kids in the fourth grade I ought to be
able to do double digit addition don't
care how you get there but 44 plus 22
you ought to be able to do that are the
Republicans really the party of school
choice and does that matter or is one
party better than the other is that the
wrong way to think of that school choice
I don't know if it's the wrong way to
think about it certainly has changed
over time so we were the Republicans
were the original party of school choice
for sure and I think Milton Friedman not
a Republican right but I had a great
honor to know him in my early days when
I started shaping my thinking about this
and so I'm a victim of that a happy
victim what Milton Friedman wrote about
the far superior results in a
marketplace driven by what people want
has informed the Republican Party about
school choice nowadays it's hard to tell
sometimes yeah let's talk about your
2013 memoir simple choices a subtitle is
thoughts on choosing environments that
support who your child is meant to be
talk a little bit about your the
personal story that you kind of work
through in that and it really gets to
that question of the moral case for
school choice right so I wrote that
because I wanted to write it while my
mother was still around as a tribute to
her and her message to us constantly was
look you got sent here for a reason and
our family that has to do with faith and
your obligation is to develop the
talents of the kids that you have and to
develop your own talents and then to
contribute you know to the community
that you live in my mother married my
biological father who then decided that
he wanted to get into the San Francisco
sort of beatnik scene and this was a guy
with everything right everything you
would need to contribute and he really
made a choice in his life not to do that
I didn't end up meeting him till I was
in my 40s and I tell this story in the
book good I met him at a homeless
shelter in San Francisco and
my objection was look you've got this
philosophy that's really Swift I love it
you you pursued your own needs you're
actually living off of somebody else's
generosity in your homeless shelter by
the way I didn't say any of this because
I'm not that bold I just drink but but
and and so I didn't it's not a story
about how I drank through my evening
with my biological father but the point
of it was my mother chose to say look
this is not optimal choice on my part
clearly let's get ourselves in another
environment so that was a decision that
she made and then I ended up with a
fabulous father out of that deal what it
means to me is that your obligation over
and over again once you have kids what
you do before rock on
that's fine now you've got these kids
well you have to put them environments
that will be absolutely suited to
whatever they're capable of and what
works for one kid is not going to work
that's right now it's what works for one
kid at one period in their life isn't
gonna work for them and you're gonna
have to switch it up yeah yeah and they
come to you with all these different you
know aspects of who they are which are
which have to be embraced it's never
what you think is gonna happen but
school choice meets that need precisely
and so for me it's not just theoretical
interest for me it's it's what it means
to be a human being what it means to
really give people their own capacity of
their ability then to give back I only
wish that I had grown up in the schools
that you're describing yeah hopefully
people more kids will Lisa thanks so
much for talking to us
thanks for a reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie